and this isn't a slam-dunk NBA prospect
he's not an elite athlete has just a
social jumper and has struggled at times
to finish in traffic around there and so
this is what somebody wrote about he is
a minimal threat from mid-range I have a
hard time understanding how some label
him NBA ready ok defense is the issue
and a big one is making a cringe-worthy
41.1% of his free throws defensively
Vonleh often looked lost missing
rotations and failing to protect around
outside of his shoe mobility there isn't
a lot else that he contributes he simply
is not a great ball handler or a
decision-maker funny actually his
questionable shot selection raises
issues at 18 time is on Gordon side but
until those numbers improved he remains
a risk I think that's just somebody's
opinion I was top 5 in the conference
and steals led my team in block shots
I can't be that bad I haven't seen the
shot I didn't like so I guess I could I
guess that's a good one I think that's
false and just view to the fire you
don't offer that a little bit I'm not
worried about this